they barely waited for dawn to break
before they donned their running shoes
and sports kit and headed out to
exercise outdoors for the first time in
nearly two months there was a sense of
release and a hope that perhaps the
worst is over in one of the nation's
hardest hit bike ovid 19 for some a more
sedate form of exercise but the feeling
of escape from the confines of home was
the same I mean I really like to walk
and I couldn't at home so I was really
looking forward to coming out and seeing
everything at home we couldn't even see
the Sun you're not elephant I've not
stepped outside my door for nearly three
months until now a few tried running
with a face mask despite the difficulty
it causes with breathing the masks are
recommended by Spanish health
authorities for shoppers and people
going outside to try to reduce the
chance of spreading the virus I feel
great
there are very strong restrictions but
it is what it is we have to follow the
instructions from the Health Ministry
because they know more than us this
feeling of freedom is great when this
gets better all of us will feel even
better hit by one of the world's worst
kovat 19 outbreaks Spain had imposed a
strict lockdown in March confining most
of the population to their homes for all
but essential trips sports and
recreational walks had been banned but
despite a falling infection rate
restrictions will remain in place
people have been ordered to wear masks
on public transport Gymboree therapy in
transport a public oh stop early and the
fourth of May people that use public
transport will be obliged to wear a mask
to facilitate this the government will
distribute a total of six million masks
across the country in all main public
transport hubs the Spanish Prime
Minister is working on a phase plan to
return the country to what he calls the
new normality last weekend children
under 14 were allowed out for an hour a
day of supervised activity but the
government has warned that the virus is
still out there and we'll ask Spain's
Parliament to extend some emergency
measures for another two weeks stressing
that today's easing
for exercise not to allow people to
socialize in groups like other nations
Spain is desperate to open up and revive
the struggling economy the Prime
Minister promising a 16 billion euro
reconstruction fund to help the country
rebuild but a balance needs to be struck
between restoring daily life and
containing kovat Michele Clifford Sky
News Brussels